[Music]
200%
crazy am i pulling it out
you got your prospectus
[Applause]
you
you
when Vegas vlog which is two hours of
footage we get out of it oh my god
[Laughter]
hey everybody I'm Gary Vaynerchuk you
know Boehner X have been really enjoying
meeting a bunch of new faces and saying
hello to some old friends
so please say hello if you see me please
say hello to somebody else and then I
wish you guys all helped the next
Instagram or when vine or musically or
snapchat or Twitter pop up you'll know
where people really make a mistake is
it's in your face story axe so like
let's stay there so if you know
there's nothing more valuable than you
reading every comment so you should be
doing an hour that before you go to
sleep like if you could ever love it
enough that that's your unwinding
everybody needs to have one right
everybody needs escapism for me what
worked out that I keep trying to remind
everybody like your number now you know
like I'm like this is my passion so my
problems to the camera fly again I'm
[Applause]
what's running after money catch me any
office hey I'm James Rossini I'm the
chief operating officer here at
vaynermedia and I'm here to talk to you
about one of our new offerings Vayner
mentors it's really meant for mature
businesses not necessarily startups but
businesses between 3 and 25 million that
we can help with some explosive
meaningful growth great the reality is I
believe in three-person teams ironically
now you might have not hired this way I
want a math person I want an art person
and I want a video person and I want a
written person so video and art you know
different skills like dust can do them
both so my video people can't some of my
art people can't I need somebody who can
both film and post produce and make
image pieces like you see when I do a
quote or thing of that nature so that
could be two people or one person right
what what you know I don't wanna put you
on the spot what you can't have as a
film person you can't post produce he's
gotta be able to film and post produce a
lot of places have both they have like a
film person that's one thing post
productions and other thing and then art
like images is another thing the dream
dream scenario is one person can do all
three i minimally need him to be able to
film and post produce for these channels
it's not just post producing it's post
producing where we can help him or help
you like that's what post producing for
the platform making an epic video I
believe them
understanding how LinkedIn works and how
long it should be in the copy that
associates it I don't even have the
audacity to ask him to be good at that
there's like six people that are good on
earth got it so that's one thing we've
got to teach a little bit
bad person and somebody run [ __ ] ads
and she or he he can give it to you
perfectly
the problem is tomorrow it changes so
Karen has to be ready for oh should have
changes again and I say this meta just
like Dustin got a voicemail two days ago
and had to listen to it I said everybody
listen like and I said we now focus on
LinkedIn
I literally wasn't thinking put in the
book so same thing with that like
underpriced over price you find pay dirt
you know how to maximize it she then
goes to him and says this is kind of how
I need you to produce it did it have a
content and media together so math and
art and writing copywriter the daily
digital deep dive is a one day immersion
into digital marketing the way that we
do it here at vaynermedia so what sort
of location specific things can we get
into as a law firm to mark it over there
like we go over we do meetings we do
speeches all you have to do is film this
[ __ ] yeah brother I'm telling you listen
this is all media it's always been media
right like it will always be media like
right like when there's a coup in a
country in the last hundred years what
do they do they go after the newspaper
the radio and the television first
literally like when you're in the army
and you're gonna be like [ __ ] the
president she's out you go attack the
[ __ ] media first then the [ __ ]
palace so what do you do you do a
podcast with a uk-based individual and
then you run ads on LinkedIn to uk-based
people its listen as it even comes out
of my mouth I laugh I'm like man it's so
[ __ ] basic but so is getting into
shape you'd like to get into shape let
me tell you what to do you should
exercise and eat well it's not [ __ ]
celery juice it's not [ __ ] apple
vinegar juice it's not steroids well I
actually believe in steroids but like
look it's not you know it's not stuff
it's the fundamentals the fundamentals
of building reputation is to get people
to see and hear of you
it can be done word to you and dad go
meet with old man McGee and dad goes oh
man McGee my sons got the chops you say
two smart things you've built a
reputation in one [ __ ] meeting for
three hours over lunch not scalable I
say something smart in here filmed right
he edits it properly we put it on
LinkedIn and a million [ __ ] people
see it I built a reputation that's scale
you know fun it isn't I mean you got you
guys follow me in Instagram right you
know fun this last three four months
that we've taken this you know throwback
strategy where I split the screen I'm
like here's what I said in 2011 and I
was right that should [ __ ] matters so
I think what the way you could build
reputation you know people get weirded
out by personal brand right there's a
little cynicism and like I as a
narcissist like I love seeing people
talk about personal brand like people
[ __ ] on it leave you know lead us like a
you know like that and I'm like you're
trying to build reputation
um how to manage your time when you grow
and your client want more of your time
right if I brought you any value in this
free podcast please yeah come on in
please please please leave a Clive start
alone get in here get in here please
leave I actually don't leave a five-star
review you got it brother
leave it you got it brother nice to meet
you leave it sorry somebody just stopped
in the middle
[Music]
[ __ ] crazy
am i pulling it out
[Music]
and finally I remember I've never had
podcast buffs some expected Keerthi in
about that there's not very great
packaging
[Music]